all right we've got a great classic
interviewer for you today Brian Wansink
is a really really interesting guy very
good guest when he was on the show back
in May of 2014 and he talked to us about
a lot of the sort of behavioral
psychology aspects of eating end of diet
I don't think it needs more of an
introduction really interesting guy very
interesting interview let's jump into it
right now I'm joined today by Professor
Brian Wansink who teaches marketing in
the Dyson School of Applied Economics
and management at Cornell University
also author of the book slim by design
and the bestseller mindless eating why
we eat more than we think also former
executive director of the USDA Center
for nutrition policy and promotion so
before we get started professor how did
you get into this topic but generally of
consumer behavior around food you know I
grew up in Iowa when I was a little boy
I just do a sell vegetables door-to-door
the one thing I was finding was that it
wasn't demographics or wasn't income or
was even knowledge ended up determining
whether you like vegetables not
possessed it was it was we couldn't
figure it out that this is amazing you
take - I get it on houses door-to-door
wondered buy all the vegetables I had my
little wagon and the other was looking
like a Kent kryptonite I said you know
this is really cool why there's some
unexplainable variation in what we what
we like and how much we that I think is
a larger explained by psychology by the
environment around us so to give people
a sense of some of the things you've
worked on the food and brand lab is
credited with the working on research
that shows smaller dinner plates mean
people eat less people in general seem
to eat 92 percent of whatever amount
they serve themselves the average person
makes about 250 food-related decisions a
day low-fat labels mean people eat more
calories the nutritional gatekeeper in
the family influences about
three-quarters of what the family eats
people put more beverages into short
wide glasses than tall ones so let's
before we dig into some of these
specifics I talked to a lot of picky
eaters I know a lot of picky eaters
generally generally they tend to say the
one constant is
they say when they were younger they ate
very limited diets and I don't know if
that also aligns with the not eating as
many vegetables the picky eaters I know
it does do you find that this lack of
variety growing up is a big factor in
people not eating as healthy or not
eating as many vegetables when they're
older you can't believe the power what
happens we read in a booklet ok there's
a study a while back this is actually
one we didn't do but this study is a
study where they took up pregnant women
in the third trimester in 69 months what
it is they gave them carrot juice to
drink every day but they gave him water
to drink every day ok and what they did
is after they gave birth three months
later they give their little bit to
little babies is so little porridge or
cereal energy this carrot flavored what
they found is the kids whose moms have
even drink here at juice when they were
pregnant with the kid end up eating a
lot more of this porridge than those who
had I mean the amazing thing is that
when you're a very young kid you're
fairly easily if you explore things a
lot and basically most kids grabbing
things and arms lightening put their
mouth if you're a parent once you kid
you better just take anything you read
you put on a little trade for your kids
and what you'll find they'll end up
going to have a lot more of a wide range
of taste when they grow up and they're
not just going to like white foods and
pizza so along the same lines along
these same lines we recently talked
about I don't know if you saw this study
around so-called clean your plate
parenting right the idea that parents
tell their kids you got to clean your
plate before you can leave the table and
there's a significant correlation
between parents who do that and children
who eventually are obese in their adult
lives at the same time this is not that
uncommon of a parenting technique right
the idea that you don't want to
encourage behavior where kids are
leaving food even though it might be
because their body is sending them signs
that they're full that they don't want
to eat anymore in the research you've
done what's your analysis of this clean
your plate parenting style
you know this is really really cool so
you know food is one area where kids
kind of have some latitude in there
during the day we did a study well back
I really liked it we call it the clean
plate Club you know not surprisingly but
one thinks we did we took little kids
for your own kids and what we do is we
sent a questionnaire home with their
parents they asked about 20 questions 19
which you could care less about one that
we really interested in was to what
extent do you insist your child cleaning
this play right you know you know it
could be a like a 1 or 2 or 3 because a
circle is 9 foot scale because to go 1 2
or 3 she was like I don't care they do
it every line what do you like 7/8 or 9
mean yeah yeah I guess I make him clean
a plate but when we gear the next thing
we brought the wood questionnaire back
so we set them up we gave them dessert
dessert we gave them a well as fruit
loops actually and we let them have as
much fruit loops as they wanted for
breakfast that day we found that kids
whose pants insisted between a plate
what do you think they do do you think
they poured more fruit loops or the
poured less fruit loops I don't know if
I would say that they poured more or
less but I would guess to clean your
plate kids ultimately ate more one way
or another yeah that's interesting
because what happens is that here you
have a kid who get wings at home he's
got no control over some food
environment as parents might eat or do
this to this to this to this so the
thing they do second they have food
freedom they just go hog-wild for the
speed we found they poured about 44
percent more cereal huh thank you just
answered it if you don't want to eat it
you don't have to even so when we talk
about the parenting influence when we
talk about the the disproportionate
availability of cheap processed food
which is less healthy we kind of have
this perfect storm of factors right now
that are contributing in general we
could say at least in many parts of the
country to less healthy eating and more
obesity
you had to say what's the one really
specific change that could be made that
would have the biggest impact overall on
child obesity obesity overall have you
narrowed down what's the one thing I
mean we can identify so many problems
but it's harder to think of solutions
yeah I mean all our lab all the Cornell
food brand lab does it does research it
all has a solution at the end of it
because you have a there's a lot of
whiny people out there pointing out the
problems but what we need are solutions
why don't you find and in this
particular case that like it or not the
nutritional gatekeeper of the home this
is the person who is either purchases or
prepares the majority of food they
control 72% of what their family eats
now it's for the better if they have a
fruit ball instead of a candy dish okay
it's for the better if they go to a
restaurant actually has a salad so just
you know big fried bloomin onions and
for the better if they give a Canada a
little snack to actually take a school
instead of you know you know get it a
couple bucks and taking a dragon a
cigarette okay and if parents could
realize they have they can't control
everything their kid does every other
kiddies they control almost
three-quarters of it if parents could
realize this they first of all they
wouldn't feel resigned and I think
they'd shape up over more and Aktobe
abettors role models that's the one big
change I think could transform the way
people eat but so let's talk about that
because recently their July 1st some of
these junk food and school bands go into
effect right and when we talked about
this on our program I'm very aware of
the fact that there are far more
significant problems with our education
system math and science scores are down
in the toilet we've got in the South the
textbooks being rewritten to include
stuff that's totally non-scientific
there are bigger fish to fry when it
comes to education than junk food but at
the same time as you talk about the
importance of parents guiding their kids
diets because of the impact it has later
in life isn't it valuable to reduce the
amount of junk food kids
have access to is there not some value
to that and I ask it not rhetorically I
really don't know the answer you know
that one thing we need to realize that
there's a great experiment I mean I
don't think there should be vending
machines in schools but I think there
should be indulgence in schools well
I'll give you an example so the LA
Unified School District well back and up
changing their menu that you get like
everything off it was like a trip Chuck
milk or cookies or like this I think
they left tofu and kale yeah and and ice
I got to compliment this writer from the
LA Times
well bang because hey you know the date
is in guess what happened over a year
after doing this Mike
everybody stopped eating there she was
cutting hell and that's what we need to
worry about if we just transform all the
school to make it all tofu and kale the
problem is people are going to stop
eating if they stop even school lunch is
what we found and what others have found
three out of four kids who bring their
lunches from home or who buy it on the
way or whatever eat worse than the kid
eats the worst school lunch available so
what we believe the solution is we
started something called the smarter
ones remove it and go to it's smarter
lunchrooms
org and what we do is we figured out
what our behavioral solutions so i'm
psychological someone behavioral
economics we've done in schools to get
little gue boots to pick up the Apple
instead of the cookie the whole while
thinking is their own volition that made
them do it and we find simply I meters
up it's a scorecard with a hundred
things that you can do but one thing we
found is simply taking a fruit bowl for
instance and instead of having your
fruiting this Nancy chafer pan put in a
fruit bowl put an extra cash register
increases fruit sales by 105 percent
well giving a name to a vegetable
calling it like a you know crunchy
carrots also just gas or power peas are
like peas ends up increasing sales by
about 30% so these small changes you can
make
wow that's really incredible it's
amazing well I encourage everyone
to check out the work that's being done
at the Dyson School of Applied economics
and management at Cornell University
we've been speaking with Professor Brian
Wansink and you can check out his book
slim by design and also mindless eating
its slim by design out now when we first
emailed you about an interview it was
forthcoming but I don't know if it's now
out because it's been a while
yes September 23rd is coming out so go
to the website school Web Design org all
right remember smaller dinner plates
that we know for sure the science seems
clear about that thanks so much for
doing the interview yeah you bet good to
talk to you